Let's do a problem on
exponential growth.
And if you think about it, what
we're going to do here with a
bacteria, it's no different
than what we did with compound
interest when we learned about
interest and the number e.
Because if you think about it--
well, I'll draw the analogy
as we do this problem.
Anyway, this is a compound
growth problem, or an
exponential growth problem.
And it says: a bacteria culture
initially contains 100
cells and grows at a rate
proportional to its size.
After an hour, the population
has increased to 420.
So this first says find an
expression for the number
of bacteria after t hours.
So in general, anything that--
When you're dealing with
exponential growth or
exponential decay.
Or continuously compounding
growth or continuously
compounding decay, though
you'll very seldom
hear that term.
The amount of whatever you have
as a function of time will
be this type of equation.
I'll say bacteria as
a function of time.
So I'll say b of t.
And I'll do it here.
So b of-- Well, let me
do it here. b of t.
Bacteria as a function of time
is going to be equal to the
initial bacteria, or the
initial of whatever we have for
doing compound interest is
the amount we start
with, e to the kt.
Where k is kind of our
compounding rate.
And so in general, if you
have this I naught, the
initial amount you have.
And that makes sense, right?
Because if t equals 0, this
whole expression is 1.
So b of 0 should
just be I naught.
So if you know what you start
with, and then you have another
point, you can solve for k.
And then you have
an expression.
You have the first
thing they want.
Find an expression for the
number bacteria after t hours.
So my question to you is, first
of all, what is I sub zero?
What is your initial number
of bacterial cells?
Well they tell us.
They tell us right here.
The bacteria culture initially
contains 100 cells.
So we know that b of 0 when
time equals 0 or 0 hours, that
is equal to 100 where the
unit is cells, right?
And so, if we substitute
here t equals 0, this is 1.
So we know that I naught
is equal to 100.
Let me do that actually.
So b of 0 is also equal-- if we
look at it there --I naught
times e to the what? k times 0
times e to the zero is
equal to I naught.
So this tells us that the
bacteria at time 0 is 100.
And then when we substitute
here, is that the bacteria
times 0 is equal to I naught.
So I naught must equal 100.
OK.
So we're making some progress.
So we know that the bacteria
as a function of time is
equal to I naught, 100,
times e to the kt.
Now, if we just knew k, then we
would have done this part A,
find an expression for the
number bacteria after t hours.
Well how can we figure out k?
Well they give us
another data point.
After an hour, the population
has increased to 420.
So that tells us-- Let me--
[SIDE COMMENTS]
Anyway, so what was I doing?
Oh.
So this tells us, after
an hour the population
has increased to 420.
So that tells us
that b of 1, right?
After 1 hour, the population
has increased to 420.
So b of 1 is equal to 420.
Which is also equal to--
If we put 1 here, that is
equal to 100 e to the kt.
Well what's t at b of 1?
t is 1.
So e to the k, right?
So 420 is equal to
100 e to the k.
And now we can solve for k.
And let's see what we get.
So we divide both sides by 100.
You get 4.2.
Let me put e to the
k on this side.
e to the k is equal to 4.2.
To solve for k, we take the
natural log of both sides.
And we get k is equal to the
natural log of 4.2, which is
going to be some
bizarre number.
And we can-- We'll figure that
out later with a calculator.
So there we figured out-- Using
the initial condition here,
we figured out I naught.
And then using this extra
data point, we solved for k.
And we got k is equal to the
ln of the natural log of 4.2.
So what does that leave us?
So now we know the equation.
We know k and we know I naught,
so we know that the equation
is-- So part A, the equation is
b of t, bacteria as a function
of time is equal to the initial
number of bacteria, 100
cells, e to the kt.
And k is ln of 4.2.
That says 4.2.
And all of that times t.
So that's our function.
I know you can't read that,
but we'll use it again.
So it should make
a little sense.
So then they say find-- this
is part B --find the number
of bacteria after 3 hours.
So that's pretty
straight forward.
We have our function now.
That at any time t, we
can tell you how many
bacteria there are.
So let's figure out the number
of bacteria after 3 hours.
So b of 3 is equal to 100 times
e to the ln of 4.2 times 3.
And that number we
could calculate if you
have a calculator.
e to the ln of-- Let's see.
That's essentially-- Well
what's this going to be?
This is the same thing.
We can actually figure
this out analytically.
That equals 100 e to the
natural log oh 4.2.
If you have two things in an
exponent multiplied, that's the
same thing as taking that and
then raising it to the
third power, right?
If we were simplifying, we'd
say oh that's the same thing
as just multiplying
that times this.
What's e to the ln of 4.2?
Well it's 4.2, right?
Because natural log says well,
what exponent do I have
to raise e to to get 4.2?
So if I raise e to that
exponent, I get 4.2.
So that equals-- I didn't even
have to use a calculator, look
at that --4.2 to
the third power.
And I don't know what that is.
That's going to be probably
70 something and so
we'll do that later.
But that's part B.
That's just plugging
into your calculator.
That's part B.
Now what are they asking?
Find the rate of
growth after 3 hours.
Let me do that in
a special color.
So what are they asking us for?
Well they're essentially asking
us what is the slope of this
function after 3 hours?
Or another way you could view
it is what is the derivative
at time is equal to 3?
Let's do that.
Let me erase all this
other stuff I have.
I think we can erase all of
this because we've written
down our equation here.
We can erase that.
Actually we could even erase
all of this because we've
just answered that.
That's just plugging into a
calculator at this point.
Just want to keep our
original equation.
So let's do part C.
Part C, find the rate of
growth after 3 hours.
So we just have to take the
derivative of the bacteria
function with respect to time.
So let's do that.
So b prime of t.
It equals what?
So what's the derivative of--
Let's just do the chain rule.
What's the derivative of-- so
we can have 100 constant out
there times the derivative
of this inside function.
Well, that's just a
constant times t, so
it's just a constant.
So times ln of 4.2 times
the derivative of e
to the whole thing.
Well, the derivative of e
to the x is e to the x.
So the chain rule tells us
it's just the derivative
of this whole expression.
So times e to the ln 4.2t.
So that's the derivative
at any time t.
And then they want to know
what the rate of growth
is after 3 hours.
So b prime of 3 is equal
to 100 ln of 4.2.
All of that times-- Well,
e to the-- As we just
did this in part B.
e to the ln 4.2 times 3, that's
the same thing as-- Because
this expression right
here is just 4.2.
This is times 4.2 to the third.
That's just a little bit of
logarithm math we did here.
And it's the same exact logic.
All I did is I substituted
3 here and simplified.
Hopefully that makes
sense to you.
If it doesn't, you might want
to use your calculator.
But this all is actually a
pretty important thing to know.
That e to the ln of x is
just equal to x, right?
Because ln of x is essentially
saying what exponent do I
have to raise e to to get x?
So if I raise e to that
exponent, I get x.
So that's all I'm saying here.
That this right here is the
same thing as e to the
ln 4.2 to the t, right?
Because if you were to
simplify, you just take
this exponent and multiply
this and you'd get this.
And so this is just
4.2 to the t, right?
Actually that's-- I should
have written our original
equation as that.
I could rewrite our original
bacterial function equation as
100 times-- using that same
thing --times 4.2
to the t power.
Actually, that is a simpler
bacterial equation
than this one.
And so that would be even a
better answer for part A.
And then that makes part
B even easier to solve.
And then part C.
Well part C is actually-- it
was easier to keep it in this
form because taking a
derivative of e is easier than
taking a derivative
of another base.
And actually we would probably
want to convert backwards.
So it's good we left it in that
form because it made the
derivative all that easier.
But we could rewrite the
derivative as well.
We could rewrite this
as b prime of t is
equal to 100 ln 4.2.
All of that times 4.2
to the t, right?
I just took a this-- Sorry.
No.
I took this and I
replaced it with this.
Anyway, I got a little bit
messier than I wanted to.
But then their final
question is when will the
population reach 10,000?
So let me see erase what
we did with part C.
When will the population
reach 10,000?
Let me write what we
have already done a
little bit neater.
We know-- We knew that, part A,
b of t is equal to 100 e to
the natural log of 4.2t.
And I said that's the
same thing as 100 times
4.2 to the t power.
And they say when will the
population reach 10,000?
So they're essentially saying
when is-- at what time t
is b of t equal to 10,000?
So we can just say 10,000 is
equal to this: 100-- And
actually, I'm going to use this
one because I want to take the
natural log of both sides.
And it just makes
things simpler.
100e to the ln 4.2t.
So you could divide
both sides by 100.
And you get 100 is equal
to e to the ln 4.2t.
And now take the natural
logs of both sides of
this equation, right?
So then we get what?
We get-- let me draw a
divide-- Well, I'll do
it in a different color.
We get-- taking the natural log
of both sides of this --the
natural log of 100 is equal
to-- Well if you take the
natural log of e to
something, you're just left
with the something.
And you might want to review
all the logarithms if you found
that a little confusing.
But that-- If you take
the natural log of this
side, you're just left
with the exponent.
So that equals ln of 4.2t.
And if you want to solve for
t, you just divide both
sides by ln of 4.2.
And you get t is equal
to ln of 100 divided by
the natural log of 4.2.
And that'll be an hour.
So how many hours does it take?
You just plug this in your
calculator and you will get a
number for the number of hours.
Hopefully you didn't find
that too confusing.
And actually since-- Just to
hit another point home, we
could have used this equation.
And it's the same thing, right?
And what would we
would have had?
We would have had 100 times 4.2
to t power is equal to 10,000.
Divide both sides by 100
and you get 4.2 to the
t is equal to 100.
And so, to solve this-- So
you're essentially saying log
base-- You would essentially
want to take log base 4.2
of both sides of this.
So you would say t is equal
to log base 4.2 of 100.
And I went over this in the
exponent proper-- in the
logarithm properties video.
But it's a pretty useful
thing to know in general.
How do you figure out-- Your
calculator has two bases.
It has log base 10 and it
has log base e, which
is the natural log.
How do you figure out log base
of another number of 100?
Well, the simple answer is you
could take natural log of this
and divide it by the
natural log of this.
You could also take log base
ten of this and divide it by
log ten base of this--
log base ten of this.
Anyway, hopefully I didn't
further confuse you.
And I will do-- This was
actually exponential growth.
And you could replace
these words.
You could say-- Instead of
saying bacteria culture, you
could say a bank account
initially contains $100 and
grows at a rate proportional
to its size, which would
mean compound interest.
And then you could say, after
an hour the population has
increased to, whatever, $4.20.
And then find the expression
for the number of-- So
essentially, you'd be trying
to figure out the compound
interest rate and all of that.
But this is the exact
same phenomenon.
That the larger you grow,
you're going to grow by an
absolute value more than that.
Anyway, I'll do more of these
problems because they can
be a little confusing.
And I'll do one on
exponential decay as well.
See you soon.